like anything wrong
released body camera video shows only
fans model Courtney clenny asking to be
exonerated just days before her
boyfriend was stabbed in their Miami
condo
only two days after clenny broke down
crying in front of officers she called
9-1-1 but my boyfriend is dying ma'am
what is the address the emergency call
came in on April 3rd when clenny
reported her boyfriend Christian
obamacelli had been stabbed
it out
what do you mean he has a stubborn on
his shoulder now
obamacelli can be heard saying he can't
feel his arm and believes he's going to
die
later clenny can be heard apologizing to
obamselli
and praying for help
after that the call drops is he awake
hello obamacelli later died as a result
of his injuries long crime Network first
brought you the story when disturbing
security camera footage appeared to show
clenny getting physical with open Sally
in August she was charged with
second-degree murder for obamacelli's
death just two days before obamselli was
stabbed clenny told officers she wanted
a restraining order against him amen and
I want him
I want a restraining order against
Christian body camera video shows of
building employees speaking with
officers saying he called police after
an altercation between the couple the
boyfriend
[Music]
through tears clenny then explains what
led up to the fight I stayed in my
apartment all day I didn't take my dogs
out for like
of course because I was afraid that when
I came out here I was gonna beat him
protected yeah I walk my dogs
does he have any property in your
apartment yes to Connecticut with
respect you know please I just like I
just feel like I'm not being hard plenty
continues to ask officers to speak and
whether they are actually listening to
her
go ahead go ahead Courtney what's going
on how's your turn
are you gonna lose me listening go ahead
and say something wrong clenny tells
officers she wants to be exonerated and
hopes to file a restraining order before
obamacelli can all right so what do you
what are you what do you want I I just I
want I want to be like I want to be like
exonerated I guess
and I want him okay the parties are here
I want a restraining order against
Christianity
how can I make myself first because I
know him and he would do it how can I
make myself first plenty also alludes to
an argument in the elevator saying she
did not hit obam Sally I had a lot of
opportunities
so when I when he's following me around
I said there is no your time is up
like that's it and then all of a sudden
ly evaluator and I said
I said show me
the card I really got angry angry
because I did not happen through the
conversation with officers clenny
remains on the phone with her father so
your question is I need a restraining
order again too okay did you hear all
this listen
who's on the phone with you this is my
dad okay in the end clenny calls herself
the victim and asks to be let back into
her apartment you understand is your
questions that are making much of
another I am I am
right now like I have not always been a
victim but like right now I'm a freaking
victim in situation I'm scared to go to
walk my dog I just walked him and I told
him you don't have a chance and now all
of us
all of us Christian to Adventure crew
albums Christians please just like don't
kicked out of my own apartment building
employees told officers this was not the
first time police were called on the
couple saying they were being evicted
from the condo clenny maintained she
stabbed obamselli out of self-defense
her attorney says the body camera video
shows she was seeking help from a quote
abusive and violent relationship but
that she was failed by the system
prosecutors say the pair were involved
in a combative relationship but that
obamselli was the victim of domestic
abuse for the latest developments in
this case and all things True Crime stay
with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie